okay for those in livestream world in
the livestream world hey you are joining
yet another internal software
architecture design review um this is
actually part three maybe of looking at
image audio and signal processing
functionality for the upcoming original
from language and what are we doing here
today
which things are we looking at we've
gotten as far as speech right yeah there
are a few things from the sections above
that I wanted to discuss as well okay
let's start off with those fine phases
you you don't okay so fine phases was
one thing that you looked at first time
we didn't look at the third argument of
it I wanted to get your opinion on that
okay so well oh boy might might do I
have to look at prototype or is it in
the main branch prototype most things
okay but I look at documentation first
and by the way I want to say I think
Eric was here yet again the 11:3
prototype build taki tools thing is not
is something is going wrong with dr.
tools there okay okay this is the
criterion so this is working like
entities correct now you don't have this
up to date let me see let me see if I do
this is let me see if it is a fine faces
new or okay no well I just updated
within minutes so
something's wrong feature is there
what's that then it's it's new
shot in the sense that the property's no
but those are the properties that's the
second argument Charley's talking about
the third argument the criteria
criterion okay now what I wanted to talk
about is that function f four criteria
that can return bounding boxes for are
you sure the criterion should be a third
argument not a second argument it seems
a little weird to have I mean in an
entity property setting you know the
criterion would be I mean let me just do
a case of this right so I mean you're
saying that if I go here you're saying
that I can get let me let me just have
them let's get a web image search for um
let's do crowds does that term ah so
that's the property right that's not a
criteria this thing here absolutely
right oh gosh that's a big crowd um okay
let's say a group of people um
okay fine so let's take one of these
okay so what you're going to say is
you're saying find faces here of that
comma and then you might say let's let's
just get the individual faces so how do
we do it image sub image containing the
face containing each face plus so why
don't we say sub images sub image is
bounding box picture of the face isn't
it of faces in each could be one or many
county boxes returned as rectangle
objects wouldn't that be the right way
to say it
you
pixal area of each face pixel areas of
each pixel sub images containing each
face yep position the position of each
face given as XY
okay so here I met so the
features okay hold on first of all here
so is it what I'm doing here hash what
would I know you've clearly got a bug
though with that though but what would
be the way of doing this heist gender
equals female
you
quotes female yes it's not a it's not a
[Music]
it's not an entity
oh great is this going to work hopefully
yeah it has been in the prototype build
for a while alright so the question is
whether the criterion so this criterion
is similar to something where I'm doing
an entity where it's saying you know
hash well actually it's not similar to
the way that it works for
see in the case of an entity an implicit
entity you would be saying something
like entity of city comma quotes
population arrow okay so this is a
criterion what is this criterion modeled
after component measurements that was
the first one we implemented you know
this is going to cause trouble this
gender thing equals equals whatever how
are you going to deal with that because
that gender thing is going to return
entities in the future isn't it red coat
yeah
also for emotion we decided to return
entities at least now can it be equal to
an huh can it just be equal to you know
such an entity as is equal implemented
for entities yeah I mean why would it be
a problem well wait a second because if
you use a string by mistake so to speak
what's it gonna do I think we can
support the entity name as well in
addition to the entity object well but
double equals is not going to return the
right thing something in classifying
okay but it's impressive that it got the
faces out of that so I mean if I just do
that without the criterion wonderful
okay so some
here okay but but I want to return to
this hash gender equals equals female
mm-hmm right because you understand that
if we if we have how can we support both
it seems to sit very hard to support
both the you know hash but both I don't
even know whether there is a um an
entity for female um it seems very hard
to it's just a word
um you get what I'm saying I mean if you
have hash gender equals equals there's
that I mean the only way we could do
that is by having some very bizarre
thing in it's an interesting idea but
isn't it
you know let's say that this facial
feature returns entities then that's how
you need to write those what the return
values are for that function no I
understand but I'm saying that then this
wouldn't work right I mean here so if
there is an incompatible change in that
fine facial features I'm saying that
this emotion thing right what you do
here is to say you don't say quotes
happiness you say happiness here
right um which by the way I have no idea
whether that should go I don't even know
what how that how that defaults and that
is another thing you need to look at um
and communicate with somebody about okay
so but but I wonder whether there should
be an alternative way of doing this if
you know this is the way of doing it
with a function if you want to be
general but maybe there's a way of doing
it where you can just say a motion Eero
happiness or emotion arrow the entity
and having both of those work saying
yeah um but what's bugging me a little
bit is that the criterion is kind of off
to the property does that bug you or
just do not care or do you think is
there any way of wrapping we can support
both in the code do we want to document
and advertise both both what both orders
prop first criteria next or the other
way around
oh gosh sighs no we definitely do not
want to document that but I think having
a three argument form where the where
the optional argument is second but my
other question is is there a way of
annotating the image to add the
criterion like that like for example
when we do a mask when we do a point a
region of interest times me is that done
by annotating the image or has that done
some other way annotate statement how no
I mean when you are doing an operation
and that operation is being applied to a
region of interest on the image it's
actually a client no no I'm asking the
question when you have a function that
says do something so for example if I
did find faces and I've got this whole
thing here but I only want the find
faces to be done on a particular part of
that image is there a way of doing that
by having some kind of region of
interest wrapper around the image or
something what do i instead just
actually deletes parts of the image that
don't have what I want and then go from
there
some functions have the masking option
not all
functions have it there was this idea to
make masking available to more functions
okay but it's an option it's not a
wrapper around the image not a rapper
yeah all right well what do you what do
you think here I mean I I'm okay with
Roger what do you think about this
criterion I was thinking that we should
think try to think through what's what's
the common case you want the easiest
right so what do we think is the common
case you think all our cases without a
criterion then doesn't seem so wrong
what's there now no but I'm saying that
the criterion the optional three
argument form would be image criterion
prop and the tour sure I think the
default is bounding box now I think
image and position and even other
features like gender and age may be
interesting as well as a second argument
you know just give me all the ages of
people in this well does that work yeah
well if they're if they're gem they're
classifier works I think something is
messed up in your be can you show me on
your screen can what what's it gonna
return in that case is it just our male
female male female Tara yeah the same
thing that facial features return but so
what's the difference I mean their
facial features is returning that what's
the difference between what find faces
is returning and what facial features is
returning it's basically the same with
that second arguing what what is going
on here let me look which version of my
running here
today's prototype though do you want it
do you want to try this I'm trying it
yeah that works on my screen if you want
me to share yeah Lois Lee so something
like this works fine faces icon my age
and then if I ask for some other
property it may need to download the
network again okay but we have got to
decide if those are entities or not
before we start generating tons of
documentation if we change it later
we're going to have to generate a
warning message first of all this has
got have them be experimental and we've
got to then generate a warning message
fine phases has been released already
this one cannot be coming experimental
facial features could be experimental
but look well whatever it's it's it's
some have you communicate with anybody
about this entity's business for for
male female and not for male female for
emotions we thought we'll use the entity
more than titties not for this one okay
let's say we start off using strings
here and then we want to go to using
entities how can we deal with that you
know in the future we would end up
having to generate some warning message
if we see that somebody has strings in
the input probably I'm making sense we'd
have to have some Pisces dozen
yeah because otherwise they're just
gonna get the wrong answer
okay what would
your features do for that image if you
say facial features , gender for that
image yeah it basically does the same
thing my question was about facial
features we can go back to them I don't
tell it what are you doing what are you
doing you know no facial features
basically the same thing okay wait why
don't you delete that so you don't mess
up oh this is the in product yeah okay
um what's the ordering by the way is it
left to right is the image so what's the
ordering on the 2d plane if you've got a
much bigger array of you know if you've
got four people in arranged on a square
what ordering does probably okay so it's
so it's reading across the rows that's
the good sorting down the road I think
and I think it's a good sorting because
when you see photographs of collections
of people and the lowest say you know
left-to-right in each row you know back
row middle row front row I was thinking
we do this down the road so based on
some combination of strength and area
sort the faces and then eventually add
the max features option that I would do
left I would do the way that people
annotate you know random photographs of
groups of people okay to bottom left to
right or they no no it's a thinker thing
it goes across its back row left to
right little row left to right front row
left to right so it is
it's literally reading across it's the
result of doing flatten on the array but
but simply sorting based on row and
column starting from top there he's
gonna do the same thing right so
anything I think so anything that
appears on the top is gonna be first and
then anything is on the left it's going
to be first it's not completely obvious
to me that that's the same remember what
I'm saying I'm saying by the row well
maybe maybe people are slightly closer
slightly further away on that row but
not precisely oh I see I see okay it
takes a little bit of a more fancy
algorithm well they're not very much
more fancy yeah it's making sense to you
yeah but I we need to look into it but I
think that's what you're saying is left
to right top to bottom and that's the
same as lexicographic in that row come a
column yeah but Stephen would like this
to be a little fancier so if one face is
slightly like a second one here is
slightly higher is another road that's
my point
Roger oh yeah I mean it wants to be some
kind of segregation some kind of
clustering or something would be the
best thing I think that would be a very
cool thing to be able to do because then
we can you know that that will be the
natural thing I think for people now
also to default:return by you you know
their default second argument this is a
rectangle which means that you can use
it in highlight image which means that
you can sort of see it in the bigger
picture so to speak where yes which is
good yeah I mean that's for fine faces
that the default is a bunch of
rectangles that's right okay
are you sure the singulars of those
property names are right find faces
comma image a bit of a bear I mean the
name of the function is find faces
plural yeah basically matches these guys
as well I think so I am
yeah I don't know for image and upcoming
image contents we're gonna do separate
functions for each one of those bounding
box image Roger what do you think I mean
the fact that that function has a
pluralized name is that cropped image
containing the recognized means in the
case of text recognized is there
potentially a list of images there yes
cuz we could we could split by line and
word and character and so we get
bounding boxes or image crops for
individual at that level that's that is
specified right
humph well it seems okay for now I think
we have to see what it's like I mean we
can always we can always compatibly
introduce images plural if we need to
alright should we go back to my screen
or we continue let's show or should we
look at your screen because either well
my mind works at least so my question my
question what was about this boxes in
facial features the third argument of
facial features we want a way to be able
to specify bounding boxes of faces and
then get the numbers corresponding to
each feature back now one way one
proposal was to have the third argument
boxes the other one would be something
like a pre-processing function that
could be set to none and the use cases
let me see if you have examples where we
have already pre process maybe nothing
in here but when we have cropped images
already and we want to get faces like
this case we don't want to run find
faces again to find the bounding boxes
we just want to assume that this is a
full face and then compute pass this to
the network to compute the features
just as an efficiency hack as an
efficiency hack or if the face detection
doesn't work properly and then we want
to do this that manually of face
detection and then pass the bounding
boxes to facial features but I mean look
we surely could train a classifier that
in milliseconds at most would tell you
is this picture of us is this a picture
of a single face so you know really this
function whatever it is that we're doing
here and we could do that with very low
error rate I would think so what what is
the real point here to be able to save
those few moments of do we need to run
find traces or not or or to compensate
for those few percentages that we get
failures
why don't you do it initially Dennis a
method setting and then you know and
that's one of the things that you can
specify our tone don't pre process
because it's probably a rare case
realistically yeah and it may be a case
that we can just get rid of entirely
okay so we'll do something like this pre
pre processing function yeah because we
don't think it's gonna be a mainstream
use case or if it becomes a maser well
then we upgrade it what why are we even
doing pre processing function two
efforts it's like it's like um you know
pre-processing arrow true or false or
something but you can also make it a
function right what would that function
be well fine fine faces is the simplest
one but fine faces with some criteria
could be some more complex function and
then my my own network that does face
detection could be another function
right all right fine find me all the
kids faces yeah
right we might need some of those macro
things like children adults whatever
makes sense now what are those hair
color things are those gonna give
swatches
aye-aye-aye swatches or just a color I
think nobody will you mean an RGB color
or some color yeah that's the right
thing to do but what happens to the
person who has green and purple stripes
in their hair a list of colors maybe I
don't know we don't have a concept of a
swatch I think the easiest no we don't
need it okay so of colors list of RGB
colors well or you could have an image
whose pixels have the right proportions
it's a little weird I mean it's crazy I
think it's crazy I think hair color I
think we just decide you know on humans
unlike tabby cats you know get one hair
color I think yeah but how do we make a
compatible change if the you know I
think tabby cats isn't an X isn't it an
X chromosome linked thing that the fur
color that's why they have from if I'm
not mistaken
I don't know um
only female cats have that tabbing thing
because it's an X chromosome length
thing think but who knows anyway not
true for humans
anybody can have multicolored hair
I have multicolored eyes oh good for you
okay that's that's less common but I
mean they're not different
they're just yellow and green what do
you mean I mean is it a single color
value no rich parts of it is yellow
parts of it is green now they can become
grey well well I think I think probably
once we have any network or or any means
to return these we just return one color
and if somebody wants the shades we can
return sub-images for I am here and so
forth and then they can do dominant
colors a fair enough that's a good idea
so so that would be something like eye
image exactly okay what's this
association of left and right eyebrow is
that so then you can say eyebrow eyes
comma image is that correct
this one yeah let me see facial features
so that then what you will be doing is
you've saying find faces I don't
understand how that works so what you
want is you know get out all the eyes
and the picture so to speak alright
since you know the eye bounding boxes
okay so in the case of find faces you
are asking for an image which is the sub
image containing the face so what you
would also want is something like you
know I
kamar image which would give you
presumably the a list you know I comma
image would give you the you know
disembodied two eyes so to speak and if
that is making the syntax very
complicated we can get bounding boxes of
the points that are coming back from
individual features and then how do you
get bounding boxes those facial features
could be bounding boxes I know
one gives you a set of points and then
region bounds could be used for instance
well how does it is there a property
could you scroll up to the top of this
no this one facial features dozens these
are the features that we get back
the features are represented how
well these ones
okay the landmarks you were thinking
about these are a set of points you know
what you should say points there because
otherwise people what's that
so for any sense this is points
representing that no I think you should
say nose points okay I see
central line and nose bridge okay so
something line but it's the point but no
but I think you should call it nose
points okay you should call the facial
landmark nose points this one yes and
you know cuz you could imagine another
one called nose image because when
you're saying um when you say for
example you know back up above you say
something like gender you're giving back
male or female whereas you know with
knows you might expect that you're
actually getting back a nose rather than
just getting a back a bunch of pixel
positions so I strongly recommend
changing each of those to you know face
outline you could still have a left
eyebrow points left eye points or line
for this one I think this one comes back
as in line okay then you better say that
yeah so left eye points and so I
wouldn't by the way in the way
documentation tolerate you don't want to
say line with a capital L we just want
to say line rocker
okay so wolf expendable okay should we
go back to your screen yeah why don't we
go back to my screen
okay what's next
so is that all we were doing with fine
phases yes I think that's all from the
list of image features from audio
features before we get to speech inverse
spectrogram array yes
we're exploring this idea of spectrogram
object we were just talking to Carlo
whether we have to return that from
spectrogram or spectrogram array and
what functions should work on and what
kinds of processing makes sense and so
forth I I really don't feel comfortable
doing this for level three okay okay
fine but I think it would be a good
thing for us to to explore because then
once you have it you see then you want a
bunch of more operations on it fine but
I think so okay fine so we won't do it
for eleven three but let's plan on I'm
thinking spectrogram array gives you
what it says it's an array it's a array
of numbers that you can merkel eight
however you want but spectrogram returns
a spectrogram object that you can then
you know that then displays as it's not
even obvious to me that spectrogram
can't itself would be the the displayer
so to speak it's typically referred to
the graph or graphics of the spectral
graph so it's not a graph you could say
refers to the graphics too but graph is
a self displayer
ya know what I'm saying it could
potentially ought to visualize and shadi
it the way we do that if you want to
then eventually convert it to graphics
to combine and out of things show would
be that converter that makes it pure
graphics okay as long as you keep it as
an active object but that I think it
depends on how how much we want to do
with it how how I think it we could
should do a lot with it I think it
should be like you know like an audio
signal you should be able to do you know
down sample you should be able to do
audio of the spectrogram and it should
convert it to a you know of time-domain
audio signal etc etc etc and what do you
want to be stored in it
everything Fourier transform and all the
parameters I think so so that so that
you can get generate an audio object
from it so you can for example um you
know I would imagine you want an inverse
spectrogram possibly yeah you'd want an
inverse spectrogram or something so
you'd want spectrogram and then you want
inverse spectrogram and what would the
inverse spectrogram go back to that's
not completely clear to me because that
we don't have an auto visualizing sort
of data array yeah but we can we can
store in the object whether the
spectrograms the short time Fourier
transform is coming from an audio object
time series or a regular list fair
enough I mean we let's do that so if you
transform that was sample sound list at
the time but if you transform audio get
a wavelet with audio objects at the
various levels fine inverse transform
you get back that original object that
sounds exactly that the right thing to
do here as well you know and you do the
same with images you come back line
image pick can we make a meaningful
spectrogram of an image is there a 2d
analog who knows well anyway let's
continue here um so the inverse
spectrogram array function is gonna stay
forth for next version the rescue so I
mean make sure it's experimental because
I don't think it's gonna survive okay I
mean it might writing I think it's gonna
be called inverse spectrogram based on
the discussion we're having
yeah but there might still be an invis
spectrogram array which is just the pure
bits so to speak I mean the pure array
elements okay okay then one other one
other thing before we go to speech audio
distance currently the default method or
distance function is the Euclidean of
waveform but Karl and I were thinking
probably spectral Euclidean is gonna be
a better default distance it seems kind
of nutty to have a thing be just the
actual waveform distance exactly I mean
does it try to align itself from a you
know time warping point of view before
it does the distance no but we do have a
working distance as a distance function
there as well if you scroll down in the
second table second table of distance
function third table there working
distance is also a possible setting
you
what is this
functions are also very how do you
specify them you just say
well you should okay should make that
okay fair enough
um I actually paused there once or twice
as well maybe I'll make it more clear
from the text above the table yes thanks
for a distance function symbol but that
would be much better
Rach yes additional common settings for
okay um Roger what do you think about
this distance measure well I think shot
is right that it should be spectrogram
is and I think that there are other ones
too I think we have them listed there
which one is it
so what is the typical use of this audio
distance is this for like compliant
comparing audience after all that's what
I was thinking and okay you know because
that's very significant for speech for
instance right what is the real point of
this shoddy nearest and clustering and
and all of those functions can take this
at least we need a default for nearest
and find clusters fair enough but I mean
we suite too but I would think I mean
aren't most you know okay so if I say
various vowels or something you know
AEIOU five times over
does audio distance actually
realistically you know group as nearest
the ones that are the same vowel or is
it not isn't it's it's not looking at
other random features that will just get
it totally confused like they're
different lengths and things like this
don't sir my question I mean in other
words if I've got three renderings of E
right and three renderings of a yeah no
I understand what you're saying that the
durations are being conformed so we are
we're trimming but it really I think
depends on the set of all you objects
that you have for for certain all your
objects definitely audio these distances
are not going to be suitable that's why
we have neither encoders and all the
other you know the rest of the framework
to do okay as a practical matter if you
just take two vowel sounds or something
is this going to work do you think
not going to work yeah some of these
spectral ones are definitely going to
work okay by the way in a feature space
plot do you have any idea how on audio
how an audio object is I can eyes in the
feature space plot is it sensible the
minimal player might be might not be
completely oh that might not be crazy
but we should check what actually
happens okay
um it may also turn the film whatever it
is it might turn it into a bitmap which
is rather infelicitous and I mean in
that case I think it waveform I agree a
spectrogram yeah a spectrogram might
even better okay got a bitmap it I think
I think a spectrogram would be better
okay um and if it's clickable and then
can be played or something that will be
terrific
okay all right should we move on here
yep so spectral Euclidean I finalized as
a default there right I think that was
what okay with me right yeah Roger I
don't think we can assume speech is the
default or or the common signal that
comes into all your distance so I feel
more comfortable going with a more
generic spectral measure right hi I'm
not a hundred percent sure I surely
that's better than the audio waveform
but I'm not a hundred percent
confidence Carlo have an opinion I'm
Specter lyrically the end was fine
alright let's go with that ok ok onward
speech ok I I thought of the word voice
has so many different meanings we cannot
use it naked Li - I mean I agree look at
the new version of speech synthesized
okay
can you update I pushed it to the server
very close to this meeting okay well it
updates what what's next for us speech
recent the size you know this was the
one I was rather unconvinced by this is
make me sound like somebody else type
thing is that right yes but can we
really do that decently well it's not
super fancy okay but it's it's wave
answered and sort of I mean it uses what
it does is automatically identify
basically model features of how you're
felt right that's great you know and
then it modifies those so it does sound
well human or cartoon you know
okay I don't really like the word
resynthesize I mean I think wouldn't it
be better to say I mean we've got
imagery style I just the word
resynthesize you know it sounds like it
sounds like you're doing you know
recycling or something which is really
weird did that make any sense or well
I'm thinking speech restyle I mean it's
part of the restyle family it's part of
the make this seem like something else
did I discuss the name imagery style
last week and and debating whether that
has to be changed as well to something
else I don't quite remember well there
was a discussion about the fact that
should be more general
that speech synthesized yes no speech
synthesizer there's no problem with I'm
just talking about speech recently sighs
but why don't you open that page then
the resynthesize page right we also
wanted to look at them oh yeah sorry my
my bad
okay I think you're right Steve what are
we talking about you're right about what
to open the one that you did open space
synthesized music we're talking about
the voice option yes
okay this horrifying thing about files
yeah I don't like this okay so this is
yes I agree I think that's a much better
way to do it and then we either push the
file argument to the third argument and
I really would like to have some kind of
a target location down the road as an
option which we still haven't figured
out well we're saying so so what would
happen in that case if you give the
target location is that the return value
here will be a file object yes will be
an audio file object now on file object
of an audio Oh an audio of a file object
audio file yes I see I see I see so this
for this particular case the question of
the location is pretty secondary because
it will really seem to be the same
object just one of them is is remotely
located in one of them isn't yes how do
we specify remote location for things in
general with audio remote not you mean I
mean I don't mean remote I mean on audio
of this string where string is the file
path is the main construct of an audio
out of karate you know I understand but
how do you specify that you want the
audio when you do an audio generation
when you do audio generation how do you
specify that you want the audio saved to
a file as opposed to purely in core well
this is one function that so in kora I
think if you look down in the excluded
notes target location in core is a
hidden option no no no I'm not I'm not
asking that I'm asking the question when
you use audio generators right you know
what I'm talking about I'm in our system
yes
Audio generate is always in core okay
well what if you didn't want it in core
yeah the same same problem we have to
solve it for all of them
audio capture at the same time is always
all of core same as they speech
synthesized
what is it called audio generation
generate no audio generate or isn't it
okay well how do we generate from the
audio generator
oh we just got this we just getting core
here which is also not optimal
especially if you ask for a very long
all you look I think that this location
thing is very much like the persistence
locations that we've got in the
persistent you know persistent system
you know what I'm saying
we want to call it target location I
mean I would always call it storage
location and I would say you know the
the or alternatively it's you know
there's a persistence location that we
already have but I don't know how much
we want to call it persistence location
we could say storage location or see I'm
thinking session is a nice way to
describe the in core thing well maybe
that's silly look you can just call it
memory core is like you know we're not
we're not in the 1960s anymore okay um
of course if we call it disk if it was
memory and disk we're still back in the
1980s or 90s or something
well so we probably say
location arrow memory or arrow file okay
be my suggestion Roger what do you think
yeah the core business is ain't gonna go
anywhere in in core outer core what I
mean you agree that's out of date yeah
yeah yeah I mean cute and everything but
its own and Steven is suggesting storage
location as an actual option here and in
other functions I'm suggesting Roger
what do you think yeah but I we still
want we have this this is a sort of a
system-wide issue we have a bunch of
things that get stored in a variety of
places we still got to complete that
survey and clean I agree I agree but
there's the two cases of the persistence
locations and these things which are
storage because this is not intended to
be persistent
a separate issue of whether it's
persistent right and I think yeah I
think persistence options should also
get added to these functions well fine
that's a different distance but okay so
this is where we're going storage
location is probably where we're going
and I would personally I would think
I mean you're gonna return an audio
object right yes yes so just don't worry
about the name of the file if you really
want the name of the file specified then
you know maybe we can use some weird
method option for the time being but
fundamentally I mean do you expect to
return an in core in-memory audio object
most of the time for a speech
synthesizer do you expect to return
something which references and you know
and out of core file currently it always
creates an out of core file all right
fine well then why don't you just do you
know why don't you just return audio of
some you you ID'd file and then storage
location is a path for that file well
eventually it can be yes but I mean I
think you can say method arrow storage
quotes storage location arrow whatever
for the time being okay if you really
want to set it for the time being third
argument that's what I'm suggesting yes
because I just don't think anybody cares
I mean especially since you just did
message to me that audio capture is the
same deal yes without having an argument
right yes okay so it just doesn't make
sense it's like no no it has arguments
oh experimental as well as I said a few
times exactly for that same reason
yeah I mean this one I can see more
arguments for it to have an actual
explicit file I just can't imagine you
know with speech synthesis that you're
going to I mean the point with audio
capture you might be capturing that one
incredible moment of excitement right
and you really want to store in a
permanent file with speech synthesized
it's just the machine is generating some
crazy you know speech and you're not
gonna want to keep it at your prized
audio collect you know specimen is what
I'm saying so the file is a much more
secondary thing just for pure
convenience but currently when we do
create a file it becomes persistent we
don't clean up I understand that I
understand and understand look if you
want to have it as the third argument to
speech synthesized to go along with
audio capture go ahead I think it's kind
of random right now okay I really I
think Steven where we can I think
consistent to clean this up is to get
where we do where we do where do we
store things and also if you want to
share you know what are the mechanisms
in play to write and it is the whole
persistence mechanism right which is
quite well-developed actually okay all
right I'll go back to ETA I've discussed
this we need hi once a couple of months
ago okay we have to we have to complete
our inventory of what functions create
file and where and and all of that fine
I mean Roman Roman is also involved in
this right he's the one who built the
persistence framework yes okay and how
about the methods are things currently
we have the generic and the OS synthesis
I vaguely remember you have done you
have given those some names in some
other function don't know where is
system versus generic good names well I
think one place we might have done that
is in some kind of rasterization of
things like the for when you rasterize
them and a Pilate and so on there's a
question of whether you use generic
controls or whether you use system
controls
does rasterize know about that stuff I
don't whether it's in rasterize or
whether it's in um well I hope rasterize
one day gets a generic rasterizer I
don't think it does now
okay it might be an appearance
you know if yes that's right it might be
my parents rules you know slider generic
you know yeah yeah I think that's where
it is no okay
go to ask somebody in there like Lou
would know about front-end option ISM
don't know I think there is such a thing
um but maybe not in appearance rules
like maybe in appearance setting to
appearance
you
doesn't seem to help many of
answers
no okay
well let's see it let's just look at
slide out for example to see whether
that has something
No
all right some something like this
exists yeah look at it okay let's keep
going here though so
so if I do speech synthesized here it
will default to my system speech
synthesizer is that correct yes so and
then I have speech synthesis voices
mm-hmm oh gosh what the heck is that you
know we have how else do you suggest we
return it I don't like this result
either but we have two sets of voices
for different synthesizers
I would suggest appending generic to the
to the generic ones and just putting
them all in one list because I don't
think
I mean I have no idea what what on earth
are some of these things so if I say
speech synthesizers I mean these really
ok what's the one that's closest to
yours shadi nobody with Persian accent
[Laughter]
oh my damn train and network with me
once we have the trainer but and pick
one of the female ones Anna I think it's
the voice option still in your built
voice goes to Anna
you
you
okay nice beer kind of shy try another
voice sure take one of the generic ones
Alan W Black is that a particular person
okay and if you if I was wandering
around CES when was it last year the
year before and there was somebody this
woman who'd been the voice of Siri and
they were wandering around with some mum
who was it it was like TechCrunch or
something like that
was wandering around with a camera and
having people talk to this woman who was
the voice of Siri so I don't know what
happened to my conversation with her
which was quite strange which mostly
consist er asking her how she'd gotten
that gig and whether she'd know what it
was and they said they didn't didn't
really tell her what the heck it was
they just told her to record these
random things so anyway that's really
quite irrelevant but I'm not able to
make this work so what should I do here
is this the right version I have the
same problem I don't know a lot of open
PRS and different branches let's talk
about these voices and this is a pretty
unusual list in my opinion I mean not
least because I haven't a clue what
Mariska you know one thing we're gonna
be doing not four eleven three perhaps
is to give you parameters for each one
of them parameters like was this a
female or male was this you know
American English British English English
trained on English text with polish
accent you know know what I mean to me
seeing this as a data set would be much
more useful and possibly even just
having it in the data repository as a
you know available voices or some such
other thing because I see that won't
work because these are all part of a
neural net okay so hold on what should
we do here no these are typically files
these are typically individual files all
right so look an analogy to this is in
sound note right I mean I've been kind
of upset about this forever this you
know we have this right we have these
that's sort of the analog of this and
right now one of the frustrating things
is that we don't have this list so what
should we could we call that list we
would say dollar sound note instruments
or sound note voices it's not really
voices sound note monster words
white styles which is what it's called
there some earth styles which is
analogous to I mean there's you know
things like that or things like dollar
font families
let's do dollar sound note styles okay
okay and then we can call it dollar
speech synthesis styles potentially
then because you know it might not be it
might be a single person you know with
different making different voices or who
knows what mm-hmm now if we say so if we
say dollar speech synthesis styles it's
not really right see what we are gonna
need here I mean for me this is quite
useless
I don't even have I have any idea what
like ah I don't know what that yeah it's
not a name I recognize immediately who
knows maybe it's a you know Indian name
or something I just don't know I agree
associated right but I mean for example
Xander ok Xander is a shortening for
Alexander presumably that's an American
you know a cool dude American voice or
something but who knows
so is this different if you're on
Windows for example of these voices
different yes can I um what would happen
if I is there a place in the system
dialog you know in system preferences or
I can see stuff about some go go to your
Apple preferences settings system
preferences look at this look at this
look at this I've got a list of voices
here
I see
for goodness sake this is crazy I mean
because these voices are all
distinguished by by language and by
accent right exactly yes
so we've got a framework don't we for um
and and I mean clearly there's I mean
this is completely crazy that we've got
I mean with I mean if we speak English
with you nah for example does it come
out with a Korean accent or does it just
sound completely crazy or is that oh
that's Korean Korean I I haven't tested
this this is a language discussion that
Roger and I have discussed as well
you know do which is I think default
settings are going to be even more
interesting that what you ask if you ask
for a Korean Korean voice to read an
English text it will probably come back
not sensible well is it not sensible is
it just gonna have a Korean accent okay
so so someone on the live stream is
suggesting how about just voice styles
yeah I mean I agree that that um speech
synthesis styles a little odd because we
might end up using them I don't know
whether we'll end up using them
elsewhere
oh that's possibility um but but what we
want to eventually get to sort of is
language support you know synthesis in
more languages right and you better be
able to we're gonna have a language
option presumably so you can have a
language identify auto-detect mechanism
but my question here is I know for the
spelling dictionaries that we have been
let's see for the spelling dictionaries
we've got some kind of regionality like
for British English versus American
English and I think we have a plan for
our phonetics and IPA stuff to have also
this kind of you know whatever this
here um well the IPA itself is
international but you mean that you have
a dictionary that provides a IPA for in
Australia so I know in other words when
you have you know the word about for
example which in Canadian English is
about right those have different IPA
right um so
it's interesting Scotland is an
administrative division that has okay
what are we gonna do about this so the
first thing is we've got to have I mean
honestly how many English British
English I mean American English are
their hair so I see so what's the
difference in Agnes and alex is Alex a
unisex voice or something
two days
okay so each one probably
fact that it's called Alex
Ralph and Albert for example we have no
idea two different voices no I
understand that but I'm asking whether
there's a I mean clearly hysterical and
good news I mean why don't we have since
this is the list from OS X why isn't
that showing up why isn't good news
showing up in my list well see if you
can add it and customize your voices if
you go to your system preferences you
can add more voices on Mac ok
under accessibility for throw last one
of the Fortran speech and click on Alex
and customize okay now so that's what
yeah the the less you get back in
Mathematica is more than what you saw
there as the download is they start yeah
us female male novelty bubbles so our
box is that from is that from like
Hitchhiker's Guide or something okay
well so clearly this is useful to be
able to see these
what they do for you well you guys may
not know but in British accents come in
many varieties sure there being a
standardized BBC English which I'm not
sure anybody speaks and maybe they've
even changed it now okay but what you're
suggesting is that voice styles or
dollar whatever we call it give us back
in a dataset or a list of association
with properties for each voice I'm
thinking because here like with Denmark
here we've got you know male and female
I don't know why for you know for um oh
gosh this is okay so that in Flanders so
to speak or whatever no that's not is
that right it I never remember Flemish
is that the Flemish part of Belgium as
opposed to the french-speaking part of
Belgium who knows they've just know that
they only have a female um well it's a
training matter probably they didn't
find the person or okay so roughly what
we've got is we've got you know we've
got a language we've got I mean we've
got the things that they have here we've
got language we've got locale and we've
got gender and then we've got um we
could potentially also extract and use
age I think either the system voices or
their generic voices give us back the
age of the person well but what happens
if I say I want an 11 year old and there
isn't an 11 year old I mean what are you
gonna do I think yeah we were talking
about this probably we have we have to
come up with some kind of a nearest
measure but if none of the voices is
close enough even error message or
something so if you wanted 52 year old I
mean I think that there's a well can we
classify voices by age do we have a
classifier for that not yet this is
impossible
hey I think so
That's not me within some public kids
for sure
yeah I'm skeptical for adults I'm really
skeptical I think it's going to be much
worse than than the face thing which has
added a bunch of additional cues um but
I think that we could say um see we've
got these weird ones which are like
people imitating you know Darth Vader
and things like that right so how do we
deal with those um I mean we could leave
that blank and we could have it could
have name here and that's the name and
then these other things are all pieces
of tagging
you
there could be a description
just to have a short textual
which is sort of uh you know these are
the ones for systematic but they're
there's something about them right
actually some somebody on our live
stream hulk yon pomegranate says most
voices are just trained by different
speakers and have different levels of
certification in terms of audio material
file size EG alex is quite high quality
voice and thus often the default english
voice yeah I mean I'm sure my guess
would be I don't know what the state of
training of all these things is but my
guess is they'll all be good before two
very long um that that is a different
okay but so sorry what what we saying
here so I mean each one the question is
what is the thing we return here and is
it um I mean we could always say voice
styles data set if we really wants it to
okay so nothing else is gonna be very
useful I think because I think that this
is you're going to want to select but
the problem is
is another one
the possibility if we had a voice styles
this isn't quite right I mean really
what we want although this is too
elaborate is a find a sample voice right
I mean really the best thing would be
you know to have some mechanism where
you say I want a um you know I want a a
person with a Finnish accent with a you
know like like come well we got some XR
tissa T like Carlo with a with a
Scottish Italian accent um and let's see
I mean in really what one's going to
want to do is to find a voice for
certain characteristics that will be the
typical thing like what voices do we
have with certain characteristics that's
probably the most useful thing like give
me all voices that you know that that
you know are plausible for Italian
time there probably lots and lots and
lots of voices available and they're
quite probably there'll be URLs where
you can go fetch voices and quite
possibly you know whether it's our
repository or somebody else's repository
that can potentially be a repository of
lots and lots of these voices yeah one
thing is that these are not yet
standardized for instance the file the
voice files that the generic synthesizer
uses is different from what Apple uses
different from what Windows uses can we
import them do we have an import format
for these things
no we just pass them to our synthesizers
now but I think down the road we can
think about even importing that although
that's most useful if we could convert
them into different systems and things I
don't depending what the licensing rules
are and so on um ok humph
all right so let's think some more about
this so your basic point is a voice is a
file and we happen to have certain files
so this is more like something where you
say you know it's more like what
resource objects what what I mean ok so
here's a question these happen to be
system files but in general we would
expect that these voices will be
represented by resource objects of some
kind
so like resource data of such and such a
thing would be you know that is the that
is the maintained by us canonical
location for a particular voice what is
an analogy I mean algae to this is when
you're searching for file go ahead Roger
yeah but their system dependent you know
so that what's on the Mac is different
what I know that's true today but I just
don't know what the ecosystem of voice
is gonna look like in the future maybe
nobody will care
I mean maybe people are just going to be
like well I just want some voice to read
stuff to me my guess is that's probably
what's gonna happen so nobody will care
that much I think that yeah I think that
part of so that there are sort of design
levels that that will survive even
during you know a transition and a so
for instance if I'm gonna say something
in I don't know Dutch I need something
that can synthesize Dutch you know that
could survive from Mac to Windows to you
know to to Linux and and and elsewhere
at that level yeah and probably other
things too you know like maybe gender
what's your point you just the fact that
it is supposed to be in Dutch but the
fact that the Dutch people are Claire
and Zander will clearly not survive
right but the fact you know Darth Vader
might survive right okay so where are we
at with this so what we've got so mmm
and I think that these properties you
know what you brought up is more or less
what I brought up before which is that
you know one of the things that you
really need is language cuz you cannot
guess huh yeah and you're gonna need
local as well does anybody hit it to
either of you know how we have dealt
with the the sub variants for
you know what I wonder if Alan has it
happens to be around let's let's sum is
Eric still with us if so could could you
see if you can find Alan Joyce no I mean
thank you Bremen okay um if he was
around
okay because I also I expect the quality
I mean hmm I think that there's great
reason to want to improve these
synthesizers now and they are being
improved so I think that okay well we're
waiting fallon so let's let's talk about
um this recent the size thing okay which
I'm deeply unconvinced by the name of so
the possibility would be speech restyle
honestly speech restyle if we were
calling these styles like voice styles
speech restyle will be a much better
name than resynthesize i don't think
it's as sophisticated as you imagine it
being yeah yet you do not you cannot
pass a reference audio to speech
resynthesis what do you pass it it's
it's speech feature transformation as it
is now so the specification could be
things like pitch shift time stretch or
you cannot can specify what
transformations to apply to a
periodicity fundamental frequency and
spectral envelope okay so I was what I
was imagining was the Buster sample
audio because that's what and that's why
I was surprised because I've seen demos
of things with sample audio but they're
not running in real time and it's fairly
complicated um but so do we expect in
the future you will be able to pass a
sample audio yes see that clearly we can
do I mean the level of pitch shift and
so on we can pen would have to happen to
pitch detectors which detect coming know
what have
to pitch detect here wasn't under my
radar a good color was working on pitch
detect you know maybe we had a demo last
year we yeah we can detect fundamental
frequencies all your local measurements
and now I don't why don't we have a
pitch detective what if we can actually
do the fundamental frequency with some
other function why don't we just why
don't we just package it and provide
pitch detect really will be very useful
what would you use it for music
transcription mmm I mean ultimately what
we want to do is being able to I mean
it's the analog of image graphics right
it's the our log for audio of image
graphics is what we ultimately wants is
what we want is to go from audio to
sound of sound notes yeah
but but you know that's mod yeah but and
we can do that eventually but it that
wouldn't be the same wouldn't used to
function pitch detect to do that no I
understand mr. Tate is a simple thing
that people seem to ask for with some
regularity I mean probably once every
three months somebody will ask me do you
can you do pitch detection from audio
and they want it for at least toy
versions of music transcription and I
mean you know the
there's no livestreaming saying style
transfer it might be a better name for
what we're doing with with restyling
yeah that's I I think probably style
transfer is the general term that we
should use for all of these things but
we're not yet there um and um it's some
down the same person switch ka is
pointing out in the future voice will be
represented as just an embedding and
some deep neuron that anyway with an
infinite collection of voices available
yes although there's still some
parameters that have to be fed in I mean
I one would assume
one would assume that the typical way of
specifying and it's like how do you
specify a painting style well right now
the main thing is to give examples and
my guess is that's how the voices thing
will work as well um
so a
so where are we at with this we're so in
terms of speech resynthesize what do you
think you think it isn't right to say I
mean it seems like a kind of weird
functions right now
I mean I guess we can have it an
experimental thing it's unlikely to
survive in its present form okay I agree
it yeah there are neural network based
approaches for these as well
there there's gonna be a lot added to it
so I don't know we can we can just wait
or release it experimentally I think we
should have ramones will release it
experimental it doesn't really matter
um so things that you can do and you see
you here there's an ads all the time you
can time stretch and one thing you can
you know typically you want to shorten
it like in an ad when you read the fine
print sure they don't sound like Donald
Duck they sell it sounds like a real
voice but we already have that don't
with we have a time stretching thing
just for audio don't we we do yes so it
does really has nothing to do with
speech which functions here
I don't understand here what all these
things just using standard audio
functions or are they doing something
special with speech special for speech
so in audio local measurements we are
adding speech fundamental frequency as a
new property as well so it's different
than the fundamental frequency okay but
what will be the analogous audio
transformation functions here
you
do you understand the question I mean in
other words for this you know isn't
there a pitch transforming function a
pitch shift function we have all your
pictures and audio time stretch yes
okay and this is a specialization of
those I mean this is pretty much funky
if I might say so I mean what you're
doing is you're deciding it's audio
pitch shift as a function but in speech
resynthesize bizarrely it's some kind of
you know other argument with strings and
things which seems kind of weird to me
yeah maybe we should actually put these
in audio pitch shift and all your time
stretch yeah just say method exactly
right and method is automatic we can
have a classifier to tell me what kind
of audio it is yep yep I think that's
the right way to do it
I would wave on speech resynthesizer
okay fine let's try and get these into
can you put them in as a method option
to audio pitch shift for now yes okay
yeah yeah and do what does the formant
shift do
you
stretches the spectral envelope that's
the third property or feature extracted
from speech signals do we have an audio
no no we don't but we can get the
spectral envelope now from all your
local measurements right but we can't
modify the special envelope no no that
the point of the current speech
resynthesize is to get these three
properties and be able to transform
but maybe you're right if we do add
audio the method goes to speech and pick
chest and time stretch we could have
something like an audio form or a speech
formats shift or just for magic for that
matter yeah
audio formant shift or something but but
I mean ultimately we're gonna want
speech restyle or style transfer I mean
ultimately we're gonna want style
transfer the general function style
transfer yep okay so I think for now
let's let's wait on speech resynthesize
put these things in too I mean you can
leave it an expert why don't you put in
an experimental context Petrie
synthesized just so don't play with it
okay I think Allen just joined us to
down is how long with us yep yeah okay
we are talking about voices for speech I
can like that you might say why you here
where we were in talking about languages
so this is a nice shift okay okay um all
right so the issue is these things have
a language and they have a low call of
some kind and can you remind me how we
are encoding that for the spelling
dictionaries and such like how we're
encoding it for the spelling dictionary
we have we have a language locale entity
that is not really released yet but they
they exist in the internal e note there
they are they are essentially following
these same codes I mean these are these
are sort of standard things coming out
of the cldr
right so it's language and locale we
should have an entity for each of those
things okay so in other words you're
telling me if I say entity is it is it
in here yet or is it not um yeah - uh I
think it's language locale okay so if I
say I'm not sure I can't remember what
the standard names are but I don't think
they have that format okay
it would get or get a random entity for
language locale should work
yeah do you know that kind of Swedish
Roger no no I mean it's an island
between Finland and Sweden so I can kind
of guess but fair enough
um I love the way that french is just
there's just one of it um well I think
there are probably other locales that
are that are French specific to some
locale this is this just happens to have
pulled up French oh you mean it isn't
standardized no I'm just I it's a
country which might you know they
standardized the structure of the
language so um the okay this is a bit
funky why are we using that weird you
know you know unification code if there
is a standard thing like you know fr
underscore whatever that's a good
question this is part of why this isn't
actually released yet because we had we
had created something to try to make
sure we had some entities that could
work with the reworking of language
settings but since that hasn't been done
yet we haven't finalized this this was
just a working packet until we figured
out what we wanted to write I mean to me
it seems like we should have we should
use these things somewhere if we're
gonna use the identification here it
should be French : : you know FR
underscore whatever it is something like
that okay so okay so we have a language
locale mechanism here so we might have
so that means that for our voices here
we are
presumably going to end up with a
language will call element oh we were
talking about gender and whether we were
having entities for gender do you are
you aware of that issue and what what
are we done on that
I mean we have I think we have male and
female we have the very basic set of
gender entities because we haven't
haven't decided how we wanted to wade
into representing all the different
things that people think our genders or
should be formal genders yeah that's
right we in the in there is I mean we do
we do have male and female if that's all
you really need for your purpose but
they're not but the control equals
doesn't produce those does it
I don't think so they probably don't
have they don't work on their own
because what is the other gender gender
yeah what on earth are we gonna do with
with them I mean oh boy this is gonna
get so weird I mean what are we going to
do with training we could train on any
there is right the
that's bizarre what's it doing no idea
why that's hanging
mine was quick okay so we do have these
my gosh
should we start returning them that's
the question isn't it yeah let's not do
it for eleven three okay but let's plan
on doing this in the future um by the
how by emotion no we're returning we're
returning the the the for a motion we
are return I assume that control equals
works for a motion Oh what does it do
here that's not very useful how do I get
the emotion the entities for a motion we
haven't put an emotion entity in yet is
that that's actually something that's
going into eleven three I didn't think
that was coming there isn't that isn't
that isn't that exactly what we have
here shaadi what are we planning strings
from facial features I thought we have
the emotion entities so the plan had put
in emotion entities for classify yes I
think so I think his classifier is
returning emotion entities okay we've
got a mess on our hands here so
ultimately these things should deal with
entities but we've got to have those
supported and control equals etc etc etc
so so someone needs to at least check
what Etienne has done in the note and
certainly isn't gonna know how to put it
an entity into an alpha so that's gonna
need some developer on my side we had a
meeting about this a few weeks ago but I
didn't think that this was something
that was going in for eleven three is is
there something that should be returning
a new kind of entity for I can classify
it's returning a word entity so it is an
entity but its entity Ward fear Oh
horrifying oh that's so horrifying if
you give me the list of emotions that
are supposed to be recognized right now
we can do a very simple entity type and
try to get it in quickly but then are we
going to put those as the defaults for
the control equals for those words that
seems weird but if we don't do that
people will not be able to get them
oK we've got a mess on our hands here um
and we're also out of time for this
meeting um I think we need to talk to I
don't know it's some let's see let's see
if we can find Etienne um maybe if we
can find out here and we can ask him
directly what's going on there um okay
we'll see if we can find him
okay so meanwhile Alan you might have an
opinion about this I mean we're trying
to return so in different systems there
are different voices available the
voices have various attributes they also
have cutesy names um sure
you know we should probably have a
sample piece of text in a whole variety
of languages do we have in language data
we should probably have a um just a
convenient one sentence I know what the
sentence should be for everything in
language data so you can say just like
you can say you know you've got a
picture you've got an aardvark you say
give me a picture of the earth or given
a language it's like give me a sample
piece of text in that language did that
make any sense and also sharpness of
audio and so forth well that'll be great
too but go ahead what we gonna say
should it shouldn't you what you mean
the same piece of text translated into
all those languages I'm thinking I mean
if we had that I mean if we you know
maybe whether that UN Declaration of
Human Rights or something is in lots of
languages you know a little lunch
probably the Bible is more than as as
many as anything um I mean you're
thinking about a piece of text that size
or like no I'm thinking about in the
retaining that was you know whatever is
but tonight the Bible
yeah let's that's that has too many tomb
or thefor the Quran or the top like
right right let's let's skip those okay
but if you can think of I mean what um
yeah I mean it's gonna be really tough
to get that for hundreds of languages
maybe there's a place yeah right but I
think having a sample having a very
benign um a sample piece of text will be
useful for the purposes like these like
like um gosh I wonder what would be a
good really benign but is what is the
purpose to have it spoken for example
but I mean I I'm just saying that
there's a it would just be a sample
sentence is the I mean I'm coming into
this later is the whatever functionality
is is speaking this sentence going to be
able to
pronounce things correctly in that
language given just text in a particular
script do we need a phonetic form of the
well that's one of these voices is
presumably trained for that particular
you know is a network trained to take
the textual form of that particular
language and render it as speech its din
hi hi
hey we have a question we've got Roger
and shadi in and Alan here we are
talking about whether to return entities
or strings from various classifiers okay
so in particular the facial features
classifier um there's a question for
emotion and for gender of what we're
returning so apparently you've now put
in entities but you put in the word
versions of those entities currently yes
for facial emotion or facial expression
under a different name and the idea was
to switch it to two specific entities
I understand okay so here's the problem
that's come up so in find faces there is
a criterion argument which allows you to
say you know things like hash gender
equals male okay problem is that if we
change if the innocent returns you know
right you get it so the question is what
are we gonna do um because we kind of
have to standardize but then the
difficulty is if you say hash gender
equals male and you know you don't even
know how to type in the male entities so
to speak how do you deal with that
and the question then for Alan is you
know is it plausible to have control
equals male do this or not
is that crazy if we say control equals
happiness do you get the emotion or do
you get the we do get the word
and where are you just control equals by
itself on a on a line or this isn't in
some function where you're specifying
that you're searching for this thing
well in it okay
so the problem is that it is hard to see
how one would autocomplete here I mean
maybe there's a contextualized
autocomplete that could help with this I
mean look at is you say find faces maybe
shadi can show us but I mean basically
it's something along the lines of you
know find faces an image , um you know I
don't know image , and then it's
something like hash gender equals equals
blah blah blah okay that's what it looks
like right now now there's a certain
argument that that that I mean you know
you could have this hash gender equals
that and hash age greater than ten see
what I'm saying we could still accept
strings I think that's what we do in
text cases how do we do it with double
equals here this is an actual function
not true true true true that's the
problem
you know if we were doing that the
problem is were returning something
definite here and
humph
and I don't see anyway I think
auto-completion for something this
ornate is very hard to imagine
um
I mean look the right answer here is
that we should have custom entities for
this
the only question is how anybody could
possibly type them in
we can make them the default I mean no
you do not wrong to make them little
fold actually that that's what I'm
thinking I'm not sure wouldn't you have
were wearing it wear it in general is
usually the you know the entity type of
last resort
exactly can't you just click on that
trip you know the elision character and
pick the other one
yeah you can but I'm just saying that so
look what would it do in a now for
itself if we did this I mean we might be
able to do this can we can we set it to
not do it in the in the raw alpha itself
control equals
Allen do we lose our
yeah the question is can we make it so
that it will treat happiness as an
emotion entity and control equals but
not in generic wolf alpha yeah okay we
have them that's what we can we can have
things we parse to a particular entity
only in the language okay then that's
what we should do
guys interests and giving the
possibility to write any function isn't
going to be always the same things we do
in this case yeah is it just filtering
and then putting some end all the time
or no but it could be or it can be I
mean I think it's crazy to try and have
some kind of I mean you know point is it
could be it could be least you know and
gender arrows male age always through 8
over 10 you could do that but that's
what we doesn't implicit entities but
it's still kind of a mess
what we should do these should be let's
make the custom entities Alan if you can
get the custom entities built that Jen
can give me the list of emotions that
need to be recognized at first then
we'll we'll get it in okay that's Ann
can you do that they don't they don't
eat they don't need to have any
properties other than they need to work
in control equals and they need to have
a name I think that's it enough for now
great that is you know and then in terms
of genders same deal I don't know
whether we should have should we have
another available do you need one for
this not yet I'm just thinking that in
fine face won't know it won't
I mean this is a typical example right
people are getting all freaked out about
sort of bias from machine learning
training right and this is in job or I
mean to true things that we should call
it sex actually I'm I'm I am so nice
about the politics and so on of this
whole I'm not sure that that's quite
right because that would be you know
thinking that you're going to recognize
someone's chromosome SEC gent gender
gender is more about the how someone
presents them or than you to prevent or
yeah connectors how the Census Bureau
tracks data not not by gender women what
does the Census Bureau track does it
talk by chromosome effectively well yeah
I mean it the data and that they report
is always you know population by sex and
race it's not by gender and race there
because it's going to
giggling right sex what gender is it
it's also self-reported so they're not
okay
but it's okay oh you're getting
ourselves tangled up what should we do
look gender is what is the only thing we
are realistically going to be able to
find from facial features I think that's
right here I don't think we'll have data
set with some other plastics and
male/female not yet not yet except
people will probably be pushing for that
um what's that we can expand it though
Yeah right but I mean okay fine so let's
just put okay right now the the the
entity is type is gender and the you
also need those to work on their own in
the language for what control equals is
that right exactly yes okay with that
discussion should both classify and
facial features return the gender
entities as well that is correct
okay um all right I'm surprised somebody
doesn't have a data set that involves
other sort of maybe they do
I don't know putting up they're not big
enough yet um okay I think that was
everything we needed from Alan and
Etienne is that correct
Thanks oh whoops we didn't solve the
problem of this language locale thing
did we
we got talking about that oops do we
still need to talk about this what are
we going to do here you know what we're
gonna need I'm sorry we need Alan back
we're gonna talk about this
ah see if we can get him back um I were
really late for something else but I
really would like to
you
you
let's see okay so
we need is a way to deal with you know
we're doing voice selection basically
from a certain set look I mean my
tendency would be to say if we had a
data set what are we gonna do here I
mean okay so yeah that you said their
list of Association should go away and
at least the names should be a name of a
list of flat strings or maybe
associations down the road I think short
term we can make the dollar speech
synthesis voices or rename it to
something else and that should be flat I
think if you scroll up you have that
list which this thing here dadless yeah
yeah generic versus system that's got to
go away well the issue is the issue
really back hi we realized that we
haven't sorted out this thing about what
we're doing with look look okay okay
here's another argument the argument is
okay I have an idea why don't we make
the names of the voices which do not
have to be particularly short
particularly not if they have
auto-completion be things like you know
English - British - female - Ellen
and do we want to allow
for Alan itself to be recognized I mean
do it that's unique why don't we
recognize it but if if what we return
yeah I think this is the right approach
if what we return in this list of dollar
voice styles
okay but notice that we don't yet or we
may be able to get it for an event three
but we don't yet have properties for all
of these languages
we mean boy swap for voices you know
have the properties but look they're
clearly here because they're in this in
this file yeah yeah what we have to
implement that right you know there for
us to have it well we just have a table
um I mean we probably could just have
this table and just look it up from here
if this is the list of voices but then
my idea would be to have the canonical
voices that are returned here be either
we can have Ln - British English
it would be English - British
something like that
or alternately we could have that be a
list of some kind I think this is though
I think this is the only plausible way
to do it is there so many different
bizarre variants that we could get into
Allen do you have any comments about
from naming of things I mean if we did
something like that you know why not
something like this and just just map
those names map the system names
this
he's got a fighting chance of being able
to you know even just visually you can
find the one you want
and in the future maybe we have some
much fancier scheme for you know
searching the voices with certain
attributes I think what we might have
now within you know within the within
speech synthesize we definitely would
like to have a language option yes and
that language option should be able to
take both regular Swedish and åland
islands Swedish
make sense yeah um okay I think that was
all we needed to and and Alan we're
going to get language look all cleaned
up at some point yeah this is one of the
things we're essentially waiting for him
is the primary thing we were waiting for
was just the overall you know language
settings in the language accounting for
locales but John's group hasn't finished
set up yet so we were waiting to make
sure that we had something that looked
and behaved right before we pushed this
out okay this is good now there's
something else that can make use of it
well your your suggestion here is that
the standard names are language : : and
then the the kind of unicode designation
or Jai Singh so epic nation what do you
think doesn't matter that much to me
this this I guess I like the former
better I think so I think we couldn't
support we could support just the just
the code as an alternate standard
absolutely that would work on its own
even if the the thing that's displayed
is you know I think it's yeah right I
think I think that works fine that the
default standard name is language : :
you know en underscore us but Ian
underscore us works as an alternate
standard name okay okay and then what
we're doing here is we're not going for
so then we're not using ES under Skien
underscore us we're using English girl
on British English - British here which
i think is fine and better
have to have a mapping to common names
from these so that these guys can use it
for these voices should it be English
British or should it be English Britain
or Great Britain because then I think no
there's actually a region nada okay fine
right so that ends up being United
Kingdom that's fine
I think that's fine I think that will
work fine okay less that's GB for Great
Britain maybe that I don't think it is
is it yeah yeah an underscore GB
I don't know whatever the canonical
whatever that can archives because
there's going to be a description
somewhere of what that is whatever the
description is we just write out that
long name which by the way might be the
thing to do for the standard name Alan
by default
whatever that map's to whatever its
description maps to you know whatever
that Ian underscore GB whatever that is
said to be that can be what that long
name can be what the standard name is
for Ian underscore GB do we lose yo on
sorry I was muted yeah okay all right
okay I think we have to wrap up here and
I know that we have some I think that's
everything for Alan for sure we have a
small amount of additional material to
go through guys yeah um when when are we
going to cover this because I am really
late for another meeting I think um we
should try to do it as soon as possible
shortest disappearing for I know I know
very well so um do we have you want to
try for this evening or do we want to I
know we have a meeting on the calendar
for this evening Roger I don't know if
we need it no we could do this this
would be fine Charlie will that work for
you what time is it 7:30 central
trust okay okay all right we'll have
some background noise but yeah well I
can be here okay
sounds good all right well I'll see you
guys and for those watching us trying to
figure stuff out we'll be back another
time yeah Stephen we didn't finalize the
dollar speech synthesis voices name we
can do that tonight or if you don't want
to go back to any of those no no let's
let's do that I mean I think we want to
say um I think we should call it dollar
voice styles
that's what I think and we should call
it dollar sound note styles and dollar
voice styles okay all right - see y'all
soon bye